so you've had like a pretty wild
journey as far as like your come up you
came up with like a
just a crazy cult following fan base um
mixtapes your first independent album
and then when you signed you caught one
with show me
that was like [ __ ] how many streams
is that thing how many times platinum is
that record i mean
this shoot i don't know it definitely
went on one of uh chris brown's like
records and i was like oh breaking
records for chris
and but it wasn't let's let's be real
though it wasn't
as if i got signed though and then like
show me came out no no no you were
putting out
other records like we did we did try
like the meek mill
right right the badass record and uh i
had a couple other singles and i think
what was the one lifted produce did
uh [ __ ] i had like a screwed up like
hook
the uh bossing up bossing up yeah we got
the boston up record then i mean right
through ferg
and and french from the remix and we had
some i had some records that were going
oh no you had records
still for the more so for the core fans
but i felt like
definitely when the show me hit it was
like show me was like
over right so then like you you kind of
go on this run where you have
all of these records that are kind of in
similar vein to show me
not necessarily the same but like you
know rmb hooks
100 bpm type joints you know what i'm
saying
very successful huge tours you're know
the chris brown story
i mean all these tours um
do you feel like that that kind of
started to eat away at your like core
following or like the ability for new
fans to come in
and tap in with like what some of your
earlier fans fell in love with because i
feel like a lot of fans kind of
the newer fans that were coming in yeah
started to kind of just see you as like
the radio guy
definitely it was definitely like i had
two separate
fans especially when you go to the shows
and i would have to like
please the core fans and the new fans at
the same time and you could see the
difference in the energies or whatever
but
i think you know
at the time when show me came out i
loved the record
but it wasn't in my head that it was
like all right we're gonna keep busting
these down
more so than people were asking for me
to bust those down like
the dj's was telling me like yeah we
love this in this you know what i'm
saying
make sure you i'm saying always you know
and it felt like something that was
simple too and everybody was telling me
oh you sound great doing it you sound
comfortable doing this and it was like
all right cool
you know what i'm saying i'll rock with
it as you know much as the hits come
through like i'm not going to run away
from a hit record
but uh i definitely wasn't looking
forward to it being like
the not necessarily i'm gonna take
credit for
you know what i'm saying having a sound
but when people like that's the kidding
sound
i don't want them to be like that's the
only sound he can do kidding can do for
the new fans cause i know it's fans that
know what it is cause like time of your
life which was kind of the first record
that
you had any radio success with was
i think like 60 some odd bpms it was
super melodic and it was just you
and those to me when i talked to certain
people like those are kidding records
like for a nice group especially people
who really know me or people who've been
rocking like
when i put on something like that they
go that reminds me of a kid ink record
or the up and away vibes it's like
that's a kidding record and
that's the album that a lot of people
familiarize with me before
show me they're like this is the sound
that he had or the type of music he was
creating